the pressure cooker it sounds well
terrifying but not only is it a
perfectly safe way to cook if you're not
screwing around thanks to the laws of
physics it's a perfectly speedy way to
cook now typically water boils at 100
degrees Celsius that's as hot as it'll
cast but in a pressure cooker that limit
source to a hundred and twenty degrees
that means you can cook exponentially
faster for every five degrees you can
bump up the temperature past 100 you cut
your cooking time in half therefore if
you reach 120 degrees you're cooking 16
times faster than normal so what's going
on here well of course when water boils
it gives off steam in a pressure cooker
that vapor has nowhere to go as the
velocity of the molecules in the steam
starts climbing so too does the
temperature of the vapor the vapor can't
escape so it's in constant contact with
the water which raises the temperature
of the liquid and that's how you boil
water at 120 degrees Celsius instead of
100 it's a wonderful tool for chefs like
you since water molecules in the food
also climb to 120 degrees that gives you
the power to tenderize tough foods like
beans and a flash
while that said please read the
directions for your particular pressure
cooker for your own safety and the
safety of your neighbors